[Music]
Brad Pitt's a casual dater these days
but his romance with Inez de Ramon is
showing serious promise a couple months
into seeing her we hear the actor who
turns 60 later this year is happy right
now well you're you're in the know a
source tells E.T that while the two are
enjoying their relationship they're also
taking things day by day and pretty slow
we've also learned Inez has yet to meet
the six kids Brad chairs with ex-wife
Angelina Jolie our source says for now
Brad prefers to keep things separate I
love them to find their own way find
things they're interested in find their
own voice in the meantime the couple has
connected over their shared interests
and experiences they were first spotted
together in November and were told it's
a pretty good match no seriously the 30
year old who works for a jewelry brand
is Brad's type and Brad who our source
describes as romantic and a true
gentleman goes out of his way to make
Inez feel special et's Insider claims
she is incredibly smitten with him her
friends are very happy for her we're
really going for it here aren't we the
support from inez's Inner Circle comes
as she also navigates divorce she was
previously with vampire diary star Paul
Wesley you know if you're scared Damon
you can go uh wait outside with the
three-year-olds I feel like it's a
little hush-hush according to court
docks obtained by E.T Paul filed for
divorce on Friday citing irreconcilable
differences the pair tied the knot in
2019. ask for Bratz friends no word from
them on the romance but George Clooney's
gotten plenty of FaceTime with his
longtime pal I don't know I just have
this thing about me
they're in New York City filming a new
thriller called wolf and apparently Brad
and Inez talk frequently when he isn't
on set our source noting he's made an
effort to maintain the relationship
[Music]